Speaker 1: And speaking of Republicans
who are in a bit of trouble,
how about Ron Johnson? Right. Republican
Senator Ron Johnson, of course, has been
implicated directly in the fake elector scheme.
And he promised us on Thursday that, folks,
it's a total nothing burger. This whole thing is
overblown. What are you all even talking about?
Ron Johnson, of course, wants the whole
thing to blow over because as I said, he's
implicated in the fake elector scheme. He had his
chief of staff free to reach out to Pence's staff,
said Senator Johnson's got something he wants to
hand-deliver to Mike Pence. That hand delivery,
of course, was the slate of fake electors from
Wisconsin, possibly even Michigan, actually, as a
as Johnson is now said, too. So, oops, moron. But
here is what he said. This is what in a statement
he released on Thursday, we are piecing this
together. You'll find out what a nothing burger
this is. It's a complete non-story. It will
all be clear and you'll never have to ask me
this question again. I'm going to give you
everything we know. This happened 18 months
ago. My staff's involvement was over the course of
minutes. My own personal involvement was probably
seconds. So, yeah, everybody just please
chill out a little bit, right? Well, no,
because we're talking about subverting democracy.
We're talking about potential violations of the
Electoral Vote Act, and we're talking about
criminal conspiracy, possibly. We're not just
going to relax. We're not just going to say,
oh, you're right, total nothing. Burger Man.
I didn't know what I was delivering
in this package to the Mafia.
Yeah. That that excuse doesn't ever work
for anyone. Literally. Ever. Ron. So again,
as I've said the first time you came out with
your excuse and said, oh, no, just my staff who
did this, I didn't even know what was in the
package. You may want to work on that defense,
may want to fine tune it a bit, because there
is a very good chance as this moves forward
that you might have to be giving
that defense in a court of law